- [Woman] I wish I had
Naruto's Shadow Clone Jutsu
cause it's definitely gonna take more
than one of me to get this stuff done.
I mean come--
(bangs)
- [Clone] Hello.
- [Woman] Whoa.
Hello, everyone, it is me, Élise.
And today,
(fist banging on counter)
I am making every single dish from Naruto.
Naruto is a very popular anime
so if you don't know what it is
I don't know what to tell you.
Naruto's favorite food is what?
Ramen? Yes.
That's obviously what most people think
about what there are so many
other foods that appear.
So I am going to take it upon myself
to show you every single
thing from this anime.
It's gonna to be a great time.
So in Naruto, in the anime
and in the filler episodes,
you can see them eating
something called mitarashi dango
and Hanami Dango.
For this one today, I'm gonna
to make the mitarashi one.
So, let's do it!
Okay, so in my bowl here,
I have the Mochiko sweet rice flour.
- [Élise Voiceover] Gradually add water.
- We kind of want to get
like a cookie dough texture.
So I got the texture.
Now, I have to roll it
into one-inch balls.
Then they're going to boil in some water.
- [Élise Voiceover] When they're
done cool in a nice bath,
and for the glaze you'll need
sugar, soy sauce, mirin and cornstarch.
Stir until thickened.
- The mochi is done.
Usually there's about three
to four mochi on one skewer.
This is kind of long.
I'm going to put three on this.
(excited yell)
All I have to do is pour the sauce on it.
Oh, yeah!
Me and my mitarashi dango.
I'm going to try it.
It's dripping all over my hand.
Oh!
I enjoy this a lot.
I'm going to eat this.
I'll just have to make another one.
All right, there's lots of
other stuff that I gotta make.
Let's go!
I'm going to be making the fried rice
that Itachi made for Sasuke
when he made a big meal
when they were a kid.
And I'm excited to make this one
because I get to use my wok.
I'm going to start with some butter.
I got two eggs.
Egg crack, one-handed.
Oh!
Gonna stir fry that up.
Onions in.
All right, this has been
saucin' for a little bit.
I got some precooked rice.
I gotta throw that in there.
(clanging)
I forgot the garlic! I can
still throw it in, right?
I got some soy sauce, sesame
oil, and a little bit of mirin.
Get a little sweetness in the fried rice.
Yeah!
Just a little bit of mirin, sesame oil.
I forgot to cut the green onions.
So that's what I'm doing now.
Oh, yeah!
That's what they call fried rice.
I should taste this.
It's good.
Okay, so the fried rice is complete
and I am just pouring it into this bowl
because the way Itachi has it set up
is in like a big, large mound.
Pat that in there.
All right, we're gonna to pour it out.
Let's see what happens.
Here we go.
And,
voila!
Our fried rice is here and ready to enjoy.
Not yet.
I got a lot of other stuff to make.
Let's go!
Briefly interrupting to catch
you guys up on the ramen.
I know that's why you
clicked on this video.
That's what you wanna see.
And yes, I am making traditional ramen.
And yes, it does take 12 hours.
We're gonna go back to the past.
We're gonna talk to past Élise
and she's gonna show us how
she made the ramen broth.
And then we're gonna keep it going.
Past Élise!
(heavy sigh)
It's me, past Élise.
You know, I'm up at 6:00 AM in the morning
to make some broth.
Let's get started.
Okay. So since I'm making a
traditional tonkotsu broth
I have to use pork.
I got some pigs' feet, and I also got
some pig neck bones.
- [Élise Voiceover]
Rinse the pork real quick
and then add fresh water to boil.
- We're gonna take this to the stove.
Let this boil for like 10 minutes or so.
To like grow stuff from the pig's feet,
and the neck bones are
gonna like come to the top.
We're gonna skim it off.
And then we will be
ready to make the broth.
So while the meat is boiling at--
Get out.
I got the onions, scallions, green onion,
some knobs of ginger,
garlic, a leek and a--
What is this?
Bok choy. Bok choy!
These go in the soup
and help give it flavor.
I'm now putting in nice and
fresh water for the broth.
Let me stop screaming.
I can also add in all my
vegetables. The broth is clear.
The bones are in. All
the vegetables are there.
This is now going to cook for 12 hours.
(yelling)
Now, back to present Élise.
Our ramen is going strong.
Come look at it.
Mr. Ramen is doing what it's gotta do.
All right, so now I'm
going to make the onigiri.
This should be relatively easy.
So I wet my hands.
Now I'm just going to
mold the rice together.
You gotta make like a triangle type shape.
The shaping it isn't too difficult.
♪At the carwash ♪
All right, that's our bottom half.
Traditionally, it's stuffed
with a pickled plum.
The umeboshi, so I'm gonna
put that right in the center.
The one that Hinata makes
doesn't look like it's a stuffed one.
It looks like she put
all the like fillings
and stuff on the top, but either way,
that's what we're doing.
And I'm gonna cover it
with this rice here,
forcefully mold, everything together.
(yelling)
We're going to decorate
it to look like Naruto.
- [Élise Voiceover] I
used carrots for his ears
and seaweed for his eyes,
whiskers and headband.
- We kinda got a smile going on.
Damn it, I broke it!
On his headband, she
used a piece of Naruto,
(laughing) namesake.
This is a fish cake, which
is also called Narutomaki.
And she used this to be like
the leaf village head symbol.
Damn it, I just realized his
hair. I can use the radish.
Okay. Okay!
We're getting somewhe--
Honestly, I will say hers is
a lot better than mine. It is.
It doesn't look anything like him.
It's the thought that counts.
So now I'm going to make the
bento box from the bell scene.
That's what I'm making. Okay. Let's do it!
So the bento box is really easy.
I have this little square box here.
So we got some rice here.
Pack that to the side.
I wish my bento box had a
divider like theirs does.
This is just a rectangle.
And in the center of the
rice, they have pickled plums.
I'm going to put one of
those right in the center.
They got some vegetables
over there on the side.
So I sautéed some oranges.
This is not an orange.
I sautéed some carrots
and onions together,
and that'll be our little
vegetable mixture on the side.
I also have some pickled radish here.
I'm going to put some of
that in there as well.
Why? Just because.
And last, but of course not
least we have a boiled egg.
Nice and beautiful and boiled.
We're going to split this
in half. Right there.
Beautiful. The bento box is now complete.
I guess I can try.
I've never had a pickled radish before.
I have had a pickled radish before.
Me and my boiled egg say, cheers.
I'm gonna et this down
next to the onigiri,
cause at the end I want
everything to be beautiful.
What do I got next on the list?
Oh, I gotta cook a
chicken or was it a duck?
- [Élise Voiceover] It was a
duck, but I bought a chicken.
So I took that thang and I seasoned it up
gave it a little rub.
And then I put it in
the oven at 350 degrees
for like 40 minutes and
it came out all nice
and golden and tasted delicious. Okay!
I'm going to do a little
traditional yakiniku, okay.
Naruto, Shikamaru, Choji,
you know, they always be at the barbecue.
I'm tryin' to partake in that.
I realized I probably can't
light a fire inside the house
like a lit, lit fire for real.
So I just ended up using a
grill pan, got my seasoned meat
put a little onions up on there
and then I grilled in just
like they did at the barbecue.
- [Élise Voiceover] Y'all
I really be whipping it up
in the kitchen and it tasted divine.
- Alright. It is finally time.
Everything with the
ramen has been complete.
- [Élise Voiceover] I strained the broth
after about 11 and a half hours.
And I also made a Tare, which
is used to season the broth
and give it that nice deep umami flavor.
- I have all my things to
assemble my ichiraku ramen
the noodles, the eggs, the Naruto,
the bamboo shoot, the green
onions, the pork belly,
the seaweed, the tare, the broth!
Everything is here.
♪Let's assemble baby girl ♪
Okay. So first you start with the tare,
which has been seasoned so nicely
to give it that nice umami salty flavor.
Ooh. Yeah, let's get a
little bit of the broth.
Oh, this broth that we
spent 12 hours with.
Let's place some noodles in there.
Oh, now we can do the rest of the stuff.
- [Élise Voiceover] Just
placing everything nicely
to make my beautiful ichiraku ramen.
Oh my God, Naruto would be so proud.
- Oh my God!
The moment we've all been waiting for.
I just want to take a bite now.
It's been a long 12 hours.
♪It was worth it ♪
Yes, absolutely.
Wow! I cooked every
single dish from Naruto.
(DJ scratch)
- [Élise Voiceover]
Unfortunately, I am a liar.
I definitely forgot a few key recipes.
Like some of the dishes
from Itachi's feast.
I didn't show you guys how
I made the Curry of Life.
How could I forget the
meal that Sasuke and Naruto
were eating during the first
major arc of the series?
I, in fact, did not make
every single dish from Naruto,
but I tried.
- Guys, you guys can see there's a lot
of traditional Japanese food that
did appear in Naruto other
than his trademark ramen,
Oh, you know one thing I did
forget, Jiraiya's Popsicle.
This was a hard challenge,
but it was a lot of fun.
My little Naruto!
Itadakimasu and thank
you guys for watching.
(upbeat music)